devant notre dame sous le parvis on
voulait faire un parking c est en 1964
on a commencé à creuser y'en à découvrir
des vestiges du vieux paris alors pour
les préserver on a décidé de réduire
l'importance du parking de le repousser
le long de la seine côté rive gauche est
de construire dans laxe de la cathédrale
une crypte qui sera ouverte au mois de
juillet prochain
que contient tellement juste la
découverte des plus anciens restes de
l'histoire de paris dans la cité depuis
la couche gauloise tout en bas qui se
réduit à 10 reste jusqu'au xviiie siècle
ou xviie siècle vous voyez ici des
murailles qu'en passant par l'époque
romaine et l'époque mérovingienne
c'est cette crypte où nous sommes en ce
moment et elle à sa dimension définitive
pas encore il est prévu de l'étendre
vers la cathédrale notre dame pour
englober la grande cathédrale
mérovingienne saint-etienne dont les
restes sont conservés encore et qui
existe sous quelle forme cette
cathédrale elle existe sous forme de
reste tout avec l'imposant puisque les
fondations ont plus de deux mètres de
hauteur et il en subsiste à peu près les
trois quarts elle a été détruite à
gueuler pas achevé d'être détruite au
nombre de la construction de vos lames
c'est-à-dire au 12e siècle mais elle a
été redécouverte en 1847 et encore
maintenant alors l'agrandissement de la
crypte nous trouvons en ce moment est il
compatible avec le projet de tunnel
routier qui doit passer devant notre
dame en aucune façon et je suis persuadé
qu'il faut choisir la solution de
l'extension de cette crypte qui a déjà
gigantesque la plus grande d'europe elle
à près de 88 mètres de long
son extension pour englober les reste
impressionnant de la plus grande
cathédrale mérovingienne de la gaule on
se pète par chick beer le site du christ
et c'est tout le problème
agrandir la crypte c'est dire non
souterrain
mon nombre de voitures qui passent
devant notre-dame est de l'ordre de 17
mille par jour avec des pointes de
l'ordre de 1000 véhicules heure
personnellement en tant que directeur de
la circulation vous êtes pour ou contre
ce souterrain devant la cathédrale
et bien si on se place sur un point de
vue de circulation pur une circulation
en surface est toujours préférable bien
sûr à la circulation en souterrain
surtout lorsqu'il s'agit de mini
souterrain qui ne peuvent pas comprendre
tous les véhicules notamment les autobus
les camions etc
notre dame est ainsi que tu m'aimes
extrêmement privilégiée il y a
effectivement beaucoup de piétons
beaucoup de touristes qui prennent des
photographies et si on pouvait faire à
son terrain convenable pour traverser
paris notre dame
je pense que ce l'issue heureuse il
s'agit simplement maintenant dans nos
études
le cas échéant d'absorber les voitures
qui viennent du conte au double et de
les renvoyer vers le pont d'arcole
c'est pour rendre service aux voitures
et aux piétons
c'est disons surtout et essentiellement
pour rendre service aux piétons
les piétons pourraient se trouver
entièrement seul ou presque entièrement
seul sur la place rêve c'est presque un
rêve
est ce que vous vous êtes fait
personnellement une opinion eh bien je
dirais que pour se faire une opinion il
faudrait en connaître complètement tous
les éléments et j'estime qu'actuellement
nous avons encore une certaine
hésitation sur la valeur exacte du site
archéologique qui se trouve dessous
je souhaiterais et cela doit pouvoir se
faire au cours sans doute des prochains
mois je souhaiterais que l'on apprécié
peut être encore plus complètement qu'on
ne l'a fait la valeur exacte de ce qui
se trouve dessous et la manière dont on
pourrait le mettre en valeur par une
dalle archéologiques analogue à celle
qui a été construit je regrette que en
élevant cette sorte de pierres tombales
ont démasqué la base même de la façade
on avait été tellement inquiet que ce
qui nous est donnée aujourd'hui est
acceptable acceptable pas heureux mais
acceptable alors arrête ou deux c'est
que ça ait duré huit heures et demie
combien a coûté cette crypte sonnait
vraiment qu'il va construire c'est la
ville de bari mais je crois que
là du coup tu es dans les 300 vision et
ce le plus grand ouvrage de cette nature
existant durera combien pour écouter son
extension pour voir saint-etienne ça
reste une affaire qui n'a pas encore été
chiffré mais ça serait une somme sans
doute inférieur à la première partie
puisque cette extension sera beaucoup
moins grave
il ya du pour et du contre
indiscutablement et la question n'est
pas encore tranchée entre l'intérêt
respectifs de frais de ces deux points
de vue
si l'on devait renoncer à percer ce
tunnel on renoncerait aussi à supprimer
la circulation en surface devant notre
dame et c'est un peu dommage
je crois qu'il n'en est rien il a été
prévu d'ailleurs par la ville de paris
le ministère des affaires culturelles
un projet de doublement du petit pont
qui permettrait de faire passer la
circulation le long de la voiture de
police le nom d'hôtel dieu si bien que
le solde du parvis serait rendue aux
piétons etc en dessous on verrait les
restes ce monument grandiose avec la
crypte a grandi avec la crypte gandhi
personnellement je trouve que l'idée
consistant enfin le projet consistant à
supprimer toute circulation automobile
devant la façade de notre dame est une
idée extrêmement séduisante
permettez-moi de formuler un voeu est ce
que vraiment il faut se résigner
envisager tous les problèmes
d'aménagement et de mise en valeur de
paris dans la perspective d'une
circulation de mobiles qui resterait
aussi dense sinon beaucoup plus dense
aujourd'hui est-ce qu'on peut tout de
même pas espérer qu'un jour on aura la
sagesse de limiter de réduire cette
circulation automobile et je crois qu'à
ce moment là bien les problèmes
aujourd'hui qui nous paraissent
difficiles voix soluble apparaît très
bien bien plus aisé âge
si l'on ne passe pas devant notre dame
il n'y a guère que deux solutions s'est
passé ou tout à fait à l'arrière et
d'accentuer la circulation sur le pont
de l'archevêché et sur le chevet de
notre dame on tombe sur une certaine
difficulté difficulté purement technique
cette circulation viendrait de la rue
des bernardins de cette rue des
bernardins se trouve d'une largeur très
limité et définitivement limité puisque
son débouché sur le quai qui force un
autre
de fait ce sont elles classées et qui
doit être restaurée qui d'ailleurs
tuchel oeuvre par conséquent il ne peut
pas y toucher
donc une espèce de limitations physiques
d'eux est mort de limitation c'est qu'il
faut vraiment se demander sur le fond du
problème
si la vue de notre dame depuis le chevet
ne doit pas presque avoir une certaine
priorité sur la vie de notre dame depuis
la façade on pourrait dévier la
circulation par le quai montebello et
par un petit pont fortement élargis mais
alors pour élargir long seulement le
petit pont il faut élargir aussi le quai
montebello et là on tombe alors dans un
inconvénient assez grave
élargir le quai précisément l endroit où
la scène étant étroite on a envie de
faire le contraire certains ont pensé à
un souterrain de très faibles dimensions
de très petits gabarits qui permettrait
quand même de préserver une partie de la
fouille de la basilique saint-etienne en
mélangeant ailleurs des parois vitrées
pour qu'on puisse apercevoir à la fois
pour les mobistes est aussi depuis la
crypte actuelle cv les vestiges en
question et je doute que les
archéologues pour cette solution bonne
pour ou contre jeu souterrain le
problème est au fond très simple où l'on
casse les ruines pour faire passer les
autos et on laisse le soleil et la
lumière aux piétons où l'on estime que
les ruines de saint-etienne doivent être
sauvés ce sera aux parisiens de choisir
ils demanderont peut-être plus par
exemple agrandir la crypte libéré le
parvis en interdisant tout bonnement la
circulation